this is an email by blood sucked and bud
wants to know this how does the Northern
Hemisphere's high proportion of land
mass affect the Earth's rotation yeah so
here what's the fellas name this is Bud
sunt but knows that most of the land of
the earth is in the northern hemisphere
it's like 80% of it only has mail in the
hemisphere and by the way about 80% of
the population the human population is
in the northern hemisphere as well right
so we tend to live where the land is on
that one so Earth has a rotation rate
that is endowed by the distribution of
matter on our surface as throughout the
solid ball all right if you were to
change the distribution of matter if you
were to move continents from the
northern hemisphere into the south
towards the equator away from the
equator you will change what's called
the moment of inertia of the earth the
moment of inertia is a physics table or
if you change the moment of inertia
earth rotation rate will change with it
okay and by the way skaters do this when
they pull their arms in they are
changing their own moment of inertia and
what happens to the rotation rate they
go fast they go faster and by the way
how do they stop they put their arms out
back out and they can stop on a dime
right right they change their rotation
rate by bringing the arms in or out if
you move continents towards the equator
away from the equator into the southern
hemisphere towards the northern
hemisphere you are changing the moment
of inertia our rotation rate will change
it you can calculate how much we change
after every earthquake because an
earthquake is a redistribution of the of
the continental shelf Wow yeah and so we
would actually change our days and night
Larry today you can make it longer or
shorter anyone the moment of inertia
exactly in fact melting glaciers changes
on the rotation rate of the earth Wow
yeah because you have mass in one
location and then melts and moves to
another one
Asian on earth got to yeah awesome
wow man they also change the rotation
rate because the glaciers are on land
and so not only will that the mass
redistribute it also moves from high
altitude to sea level okay so now you're
changing how far away the matter is from
the rotation axis of the earth all this
conspires to influence our rotation rate
I if you know what I'm gonna tell you I
never thought you would give that much
information